on this Friday night fed up and fired up
over George Floyd's death the charges
just filed and a new chorus of
condemnation against police for this why
am i under arrest
New Brunswick's growing Kovan 19
outbreak traced to a doctor the
consequences for him and ramifications
for his small community a mother's
gratitude we've seen a glimpse of the
Sun that we used to know how the
pandemic has been a saving grace for her
son and wild pool party of one the
unexpected guest making a splash
global national we've done a freezing
reporting tonight after a night of
violent unrest in Minneapolis protests
are spreading over the death of a black
man in police custody from Phoenix to
Denver to Louisville and Los Angeles
people across the u.s. are outraged
demanding justice for George Floyd good
evening and thank you for joining us
four days after Floyd's death there's
been a major development in the case
then now former police officer Derek
shavon who was captured on video
kneeling on George Floyd's neck as he
gasped for air has been charged with
murder three other officers were part of
the arrest they were also fired but
haven't been charged the governor of
Minnesota is promising swift justice for
all the officers involved
he's also appealing for calm and at the
same time he's acknowledging the hurt
caused by institutional racism and so
many deadly interactions between black
Americans and police Minneapolis and st.
Paul are on fire the fires still smolder
in our streets the ashes are symbolic of
decades and generations of a pain of
anguish unheard much like we failed to
hear George Floyd as he pleaded for his
life as the world watched Floyd's death
was the spark that ignited a firestorm
in Minneapolis and tonight an uneasy
tension remains across the city today
journalists covering the city's violent
reaction were arrested on live
television by state police and as
Jackson prosecco reports were learning
more about what happened in the final
minutes before Floyd's death a deep
sense of unease hangs over Minneapolis
after another night of chaos protesters
clashed with police and set a local
precinct ablaze the mayor decided in
this tense powder-keg better to let the
building burn the symbolism of a
building cannot
outweigh the importance of life of our
officers or the public we could not risk
serious injury to anyone the governor
called in the National Guard to patrol
the streets instead of the city's
embattled police force appealing for a
return to order as a way to move forward
help us use humane way to get the
streets to a place where we can restore
the justice so that those that are
expressing rage and anger and demanding
justice are heard but the deep wounds
are not quick to heal the protests
aren't just about the death of George
Floyd they're about a pain that spans
generations
you know the arrest of former police
officer Derek Chavan
the man seen kneeling on the neck of the
unarmed Floyd make well some of the
anger we felt it appropriate to focus on
the most dangerous perpetrator I must
say that this case is moved with
extraordinary speed chauvinism murder
and manslaughter charging documents
allege he kept his knee on Floyd's neck
for 2 minutes and 43 seconds after Floyd
became unresponsive the other three
arresting officers two of whom were seen
kneeling on Floyd are also expected to
face charges we want to see for arrest
and charges for everything that they did
that violated the law but there is much
more work to do to restore trust in
authorities after the past week ok I am
under a CNN reporter was arrested on
live television by Minnesota State
Police while his white colleagues were
untouched while on the burnt-out streets
of Minneapolis dozens of businesses are
left to pick up the pieces after being
looted and vandalized
you know we've been working so hard but
it's please no there's an ideas for me
it's my family
Jaxson the former police officer is
charged with third-degree murder
something Canada does not have what is
the penalty involved in this in fact
most states don't have this charge Robin
it's a depraved indifference murder in
other words the allegation is that the
person caused bodily harm but did not
set out to kill someone the district
attorney pointed out it's quite possible
that more charges could be added so this
may not be the final charge at that
officer faces at this point and Jackson
late today President Trump spoke about
the situation in Minneapolis what did he
have to say yeah this is certainly a
moment of national angst and anger in
this country and the president has been
Fanning the flames largely from the
sidelines late this afternoon he did
appear in front of the cameras to say he
had spoken with George
Floyd's family and offered his
condolences but it's a series over of
overnight tweets that have really raised
concerns in those tweets the president
called the protesters quote thugs he
went on to say that quote when the
looting starts the shooting starts and
that phrase is widely acknowledged as a
racist trope that dates back to the
1960s the tweet was actually flagged by
Twitter for what they say was glorifying
violence Trump later says he spoke the
words as a fact not a statement Joe
Biden also addressed the nation today
saying he too spoke with Floyd's family
saying that the nation the very soul of
the nation is at stake and former
President Barack Obama also weighed in
with a statement of his own saying that
what happened to Floyd
should not be normal in the America of
2020 Robin Jackson prosecco in
Washington thanks Jackson
NBC's Morgan Chesky is in Minneapolis
tonight he joins us now Morgan how are
the people they're reacting to the news
of the former police officer being
charged robbing a good evening they're
certainly acknowledging Chauvin arrest
is a positive step towards justice but
there are quite a few people here in
this very crowd we're standing in right
now just a few blocks away from that
third precinct that believe that even
third-degree murder is not enough
considering what these that men did to
George Floyd one arrest has happened we
do know that three more potential
arrests could take place with those
other officers that were involved in his
death but it really is a mixed emotions
right now in this crowd that the past
two days were calling for justice
calling for something to be done and
upon hearing of Chauvin surest today
have acknowledged it but now they want
to see what comes next
Robin has it diffused the anger at all
during the day we have seen relatively
calm crowds here Robin and so as far as
the anger that will really be a time
will tell we know that the majority of
the destruction that's happened here in
southern Minneapolis has come after
nightfall that's when these peaceful
crowds that you see behind me are joined
or replaced altogether by a much more
destructive group of people intent on
inflicting as much damage as they can in
this area
now if tempers die down we should see a
hopeful change tonight and one thing
that could help with that is a citywide
curfew that has been put into place by
the mayor of Minneapolis starting at
8:00 p.m. Friday night and that will
last throughout the weekend and with
that in place with the addition of these
state patrol officers and the arrival of
the National Guard today those elements
combined sure to hopefully stop what
we've witnessed the past two nights
which essentially have been a
free-for-all in certain areas of the
city where people have been able to
break into businesses take what they
want
I continue to loot start fires and cause
significant damage to this part of the
city robbing a lot of eyes are on the
police how are they managing the
situation now Robin I think they're
managing it as carefully as they can
because they just know how much how many
passion people there are in this crowd
and how quickly tempers can rise
considering what we've seen over the
past several days we know that as it
stands right now they have full riot
gear on they're maintaining a very very
tight perimeter around that damaged area
and that looks to be the plan going
forward we anticipated what they're
doing today last night when we were
reporting just a block or two away from
that third precinct but whenever
protesters started to approach that
building and gained access to it the
police presence that was inside there
vacated the area and that is really when
we watch this crowd move from one
building to another and so it's been a
very contrasting style in strategies
from yesterday until today
and we can only hope that that means
that the damage that we've seen finally
comes to a stop here in Minneapolis this
is a community that has been very much
left in shock as a result of the death
of George Floyd and so those who live
nearby have come out witnessed the
devastation for themselves and it's
tough even for them to believe when they
see it firsthand and you combined that
with the people that have driven in here
to send a message and it leaves a very
surreal experience for this city that is
now trying to grieve the loss of George
Floyd but also begin to pick up the
pieces from just so much damage
Robinson Morgan Chesky in Minneapolis
tonight thanks Morgan to the köppen 19
pandemic now the New Brunswick doctor
linked to a cluster of new cases has now
been suspended he travelled outside the
province and failed to self isolate
before returning to work New Brunswick
until now appear to have the virus under
control but as Ross Lord reports
restrictions are now being reimpose as
people scramble to get tested in your
Brunswick they're learning it only takes
one person's poor judgment to stain a
spotless record after announcing this
month all 120 people with covered 19 had
recovered there's a growing outbreak in
the small community of campbellton we
have two new active cases today bringing
the number of active cases to eight one
of the cases is an employee at a
long-term special care facility there
were about 50 residents in that facility
and again they've all we have a rapid
deployment team that was sent there to
test them all the person blamed for
spreading the virus is a doctor who
traveled to Quebec and decided not to
self isolate after returning to New
Brunswick in fact the doctor saw
patients at this hospital and possibly
other locations for two weeks he's been
suspended indefinitely and the RCMP is
investigating possible criminal
wrongdoing the Koster has caused the
province to reverse some loosening
measures in the campbellton area forcing
a return to a two-family bubble some
campbellton businesses that were closed
then reopened are imposing restrictions
again we at least lost 30% of our
clientele reopening the first time but
now reopening again I think people might
be scared to actually come to public
places so we could lose a lot more
clients again else
the decision of one person so I'm not
blaming all the healthcare I'm blaming
the first took the decision to do this
to the region we have hundreds of people
that came in our restaurants in the past
two weeks though where we do like
everybody else and we'll get tested and
hopefully we're all good for a province
that took pride in suppressing the virus
it's a troubling reminder of how easily
it can reappear to slow reopening and
increase anxiety
Ross Lord Global News Ontario which is
struggling to meet its daily testing
goals is expanding its Cova 19 testing
strategy the targeted campaign will
focus on first responders workers at
select hospitals staff and inmates in
some correctional facilities those who
work at liquor stores and people who
live in vulnerable communities like
long-term care homes pop-up assessment
centers and mobile testing units will be
used in the provinces hardest hit areas
Ontario's premier says the expanded
testing strategy is the best defense
against the virus as the province
reopens
he's also considering regional reopening
premiere for joined all the premiers
from across the country in a virtual
meeting with the prime minister last
night their eleventh weekly meeting
since the pandemic began one of the key
issues discussed long-term care homes
our chief political correspondent David
Icke and joins us now for more on the
meeting and what was decided David well
Robin the prime minister in the premiers
met for about 90 minutes last night and
when it was over the PMO issued a
statement saying that they agreed to
take action to improve care for seniors
but today the prime minister was vague
when we asked him what specific action
he will take we have said at the federal
level that we will be there to support
the provinces both in the immediate
whether it's more rent money or more
resources or whatever it is that the
provinces need to get control once again
over their long-term care facilities and
there was no word on whether the federal
government will set national standards
for long-term care facilities that's
something a lot of experts are calling
for
we will be there for those conversations
in the medium and long term but right
now we're still dealing with this
emergency of getting people to support
they need now earlier this week five
Liberal MPs all from the Greater Toronto
Area sent an open letter to the prime
minister asking that Ottawa get to work
building quote enforceable national
standards now those five Liberal MPs had
a meeting this morning with Health
Minister Patti Heidi I'm told it was a
productive meeting
but the Trudeau Liberals do not want to
pick a fight with the provinces over
this and I'm told Quebec does not want a
national anything so if they do wish to
proceed it's going to be in cooperation
with the provinces Robyn
David akin in Ottawa Canada's cruise
control extended coming up when these
ships can be allowed back in Canadian
waters
québec's Education Department says a
total of 41 students and teachers have
tested positive for köppen 19 since
elementary schools reopened on May 11th
a survey of school boards found that 19
students and 22 staff members have
become infected the province has allowed
elementary schools outside the Montreal
area to reopen but canceled the rest of
the school year in the city itself the
province now has more than 50,000
confirmed cases of covin 19 the federal
government is providing First Nations
communities with more funding to help
them cope with the pandemic Ottawa plans
to spend another 650 million dollars to
help pay for supplies medical care and
facilities to allow for social
distancing the on reserved income
assistance program will increase by two
hundred and seventy million dollars to
ensure families don't have to choose
between food and rent right now and more
than forty four million dollars will be
spent over five years to build 12
shelters in indigenous communities for
women and children fleeing violence
changes could be coming to restrictions
at the us-canada border the Prime
Minister says he's looking at ways to
help reunite families stranded on either
side of the border by the Cova 19
restrictions this would not change the
approach on foot closing the borders
until the end of June and depending on
discussions beyond but it is looking at
can we support families that are going
through extremely difficult times we
will continue to engage with them we
will continue to look into this matter
and ensure that no matter what we do we
are keeping the safety of Canadian and
well-being of Canadians at the forefront
of any decision the federal government
extended its ban on cruise ships until
the end of October in March the
government banned cruise ships carrying
more than 500 people until July but
today Transport Minister Marc Garneau
said cruise ships with more than a
hundred people are no longer allowed to
visit Canadian waters or dock at ports
in Canada until at least October 31st if
they break the rules
the companies face fines of twenty five
thousand dollars still ahead how Coppa
19 is changing how some battle drug
addiction
fentanyl and other opioids can slow a
person's breathing so covert 19 which
attacks the respiratory system can
increase the risk of dying for those who
use these drugs in some parts of the
country harm reduction programs have
been helping our Heather York's West
shows us how one family has benefited
from what they call a blessing Keegan
Tierney has battled drug addiction for
close to 10 years it's a struggle
especially the last couple years then
homeless
you know just jail everything's just
it's been like hell but the last few
weeks have been different and Tierney
says he has the corona virus pandemic -
think we've seen a glimpse of the Sun
that we used to know and it's been a
long time since we've seen that when
tyranny came out of a detox program in
April a local charity offered him a
chance to self isolate in a hotel and
each day a mobile therapy program comes
to him so basically instead of doing
fentanyl and they give you a dose of
hydro morphine as well as methadone or
suboxone and kind of slowly decrease
that dose until you're ready to be
completely sober this is a place where
we really really could use massive scale
up and that would be very very helpful
in addressing both the kulluk pandemic
and the overdose crisis harm reduction
advocates believe initiatives that
provide a so-called safe supply to those
experiencing addiction are vital both
now and after physical distancing
measures end in March BC became the
first province in the country to
introduce clinical guidance around the
prescription of pharmaceutical grade
controlled substances as a form of harm
reduction really this is our opportunity
to see how acceptable how many people
will be willing to prescribe so it's a
guidance document that has been
introduced because of komen but
obviously you would hope that safer
supply and pharmaceutical alternatives
continue after mid-19th to stay here
until at least the end of August
enough time he says to make a plan for
what's next
Heather your ex West global news Calgary
up next higher risks the question that's
sparking great debate about Cova 19
as restrictions ease across the country
the number of kovat 19 cases could rise
and many Canadians are wondering if the
changes will put them at risk our Geoff
sample has taken your questions straight
to the experts your chances of catching
kovat 19 depend a lot on where you live
Dave from Ottawa asks our people in
apartment buildings at a higher risk yes
only in that you are more likely to
encounter different kinds of people in
the elevator but not all apartments are
created equal the City of Toronto just
released this interactive map that
reveals kovat cases by neighborhood
downtown there are relatively few
compared with neighbourhoods to the
north you're seeing that is
disproportionately affecting people of
lower income this North Toronto
neighbourhood Glenfield Jane Heights is
home to the city's highest number of
kovat 19 cases and like many other
hotspots it's also home to a lot of
multi-unit low-income housing if they're
living at home with seven family members
in a two-bedroom apartment with one
bathroom the ability for that person to
safely quarantine themselves as next to
impossible Jackie from abbotsford asks
why do more women appear to be affected
by kovat 19 than men in most countries
men have been the hardest hit in Italy
71 percent of victims were male
behaviors in general men are more likely
to smoke to take less good care of
themselves but in Canada women are
bearing the brunt a recent report found
53 percent of Canada's kovat 19 deaths
were women the highest proportion of any
country experts point to the site of
Canada's worst outbreaks women are much
more likely to work and live in
long-term care homes women are are
certainly over-represented in in the
long-term care facilities
simply because women live longer than
men Droid asks if smokers including
cannabis smokers are more vulnerable to
the virus a question that's sparking
some debate a few recent studies have
actually
suggested nicotine or cannabis might
offer some protection against kovat 19
but many experts believe they're blowing
smoke any type of smoking related
activity can most likely put you at
higher risk so but again you know I
could be wrong and I wouldn't come to
that conclusion till we know all of the
data data from thorough peer-reviewed
studies which for a new virus is still
largely lacking leaving many questions
about who's most at risk unanswered at
least for now
Jeff sample Global News Toronto and that
is global national for this Friday I'm
Robin Gill with heat waves rolling
through Canada we leave you tonight with
the wild way a Canadian symbol managed
to cool off this moose was caught taking
a dip in an Ottawa man's pool the
trespasser treaded water for hours
before jumping out and then over the
fence thank you for watching I'll see
you back here tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]